I've often thought about how the state
of American mathematics excellent v if
mathematics were popularized more the
same way that basketball is popularized
for then more people will know that
there is something to reach for
I think will be extremely valuable have
more people know that there are these
amazing challenges to reach for an
athletics to inspire more people to try
to do them
so in high school there is a series of
math competitions and what it's all
supposed to lead up to is the IMO the
International mathematics competition
and every year 50 or so people are
invited to a math camp the math Olympiad
summer program and it's both people who
made the team and people who we think
are promising and have a chance to make
it in future years so what is the math
Olympiad summer program it's a way for
mathematicians young mathematicians to
interact with other incredible young
mathematicians from both the United
States and now around the world during
the math Olympia summer program we have
courses during the day where the courses
will discuss sort of mathematics that
they might see in the International math
Olympia as well as a sort of mathematics
that they might see later in some sense
we try to encourage them to have a
attitude that competitions are
interesting but they are not the end of
the line in fact I'd say that they're
the beginning of a very very long road
towards mathematics research or other
research the the program has been
described as perhaps intense or or
rigorous however we always get a lot of
requests from students of more math
because this is actually a playground
for people who love mathematics to see
interesting things that they may not
have had access to see before at their
home I find that's beautiful I don't
really recall when and how I fell in
love with the subject in general Max is
not very popular in India it's very hard
to find people who like mathematics here
I'm finding actually 70 people who share
to explore and who love mathematics
together you could learn about math and
be with dozens of people who were just
as passionate about math as you are and
then just have this experience of
learning from other people people who
are really good at math and just
improving your mathematical abilities
that you get to meet people from around
the world and for u.s. citizens not just
from within the US and that's nice
because like maybe people from different
countries might have different
perspectives or like have different
views and stuff that you might not know
about and it's just nice to be able to
be
two different views it turns out when
you gather fifty kids who all have this
shared interest in math and logic and
nerdy stuff everyone is just excited
about the same kind of thing and for
three weeks being in an environment with
people who have the same mindset as you
is almost freeing the people here are
really spectacular there's an incredible
community between the students in these
structures people who all enjoy very
similar things and then also end up
becoming very good friends invited by
the end and so outside of classes
there's a lot of activities that happen
at any time at any time of the day
really the social interactions that
happen are basically the foundations of
future collaborations that happen as
students move on and move into research
or into industry at the end of the day
the instructor and assistant group is a
rather tight-knit community of people
who are very passionate about the math
Olympia's math competitions but also
about trying to help the next generation
move forward and make the most of their
talents I keep coming back to mop
because it's fun really math is about
creatively solving problems and finding
truths that were always there and mop is
more about the the creative side all the
interesting things that you'll find in
math if you poke around it's not about
winning a competition in the end it's
about these skills that you gather and
can use later on the creative
problem-solving some people say that the
real skill is being able to solve
problems and math is the easiest way to
gain that skill what stays with you is
how to approach problems and how to
think creatively and logically to solve
problems here at mop not only do I learn
much more advanced techniques in
advanced approaches to elementary math
but you also get some some idea of what
higher math is like and I feel that that
gives a sort of way of thinking and
intuition which which can help you a lot
solving even Olympia's problems all the
math I learned here would of course be
useful in competitions math later but
also like the way they teach us how to
approach problems and like think about
problems it's also really useful in real
life so like if you're facing a problem
like any situation really
you can like think about all your
possibilities like thank you logically
and just like stay calm if you stay calm
you might be able to solve the problem
so like those like small techniques can
actually help you in real life and I
think that's something that's really
cool too I try different things and use
strategies to think of ways that you can
solve the problem that's going to be the
thing that will stay with me throughout
my life I feel that it's it's very
useful also to make make your mind
faster to just own your skills my
primary goal was not actually winning
the International math Olympia because I
would like to focus on the 20 year
success trajectory of all of these
students so we have a responsibility to
help these people not only succeed in
the competitions but to be as productive
as possible in their future careers and
hopefully leave some massive impact on
the country and the world so this has
actually been my central theme this is
why the math Olympiad summer program has
seminars in the evenings which have
nothing to do with Olympian mathematics
but consist of the people who are gone
through the program talking about what
we actually do now and how to take that
bridge from what the high school
students have today to do what we do now
I try to see how much passion the
students have towards the various things
that work that they are working on and
whether or not we've managed to
communicate why those things are
interesting at the end of the day I
guess every single day at not when I
sing galore every single day when I'm
working with students I have this
internal measure of what is the energy
level in the
and my goal is to keep the energy levels
high so high that a very end we don't
have a bunch of we don't have 70
students were all burned out but rather
70 students who want more